we want to bring in the u.s surgeon
general that's dr vivek morthy dr morty
good morning to you thank you for
joining us uh back in february uh
president biden said that his hope was
that by this christmas we'd be back to
normal that's obviously not where we are
so with that in mind what's his message
to americans tomorrow
well tony on tuesday what you're going
to hear president biden speak to the
country about is what we can expect in
the weeks ahead and the steps also that
the government is taking to make sure
that we do as much as possible to
protect people across the country look
in the in coming weeks uh tony we are
going to see a spike in cases
and that's because omicron is incredibly
transmissible and you know we we have to
be prepared for that but there will be a
stark difference between the experience
of those who are vaccinated and boosted
versus those who are unvaccinated you
know with those who who have maximal
protection from a vaccination and a
boost you either won't get infected or
if you do get an infection it will be
most likely mild but if you are
unvaccinated i'm worried about you i'm
worried that your risk of being
hospitalized or god forbid losing your
life to this virus is is quite
significant so you know it still remains
the case that getting vaccinated and
boosted is the best way to protect
yourself even against omicron
doctor as the administration tries to
figure out what to recommend and when to
recommend it i'm curious how you're
going to be defining success and what
measures you think are most important is
it case count or as we've been hearing
from other doctors is it really
hospitalizations that we should be
paying attention to
well it's an important question and the
most important metrics for sure
are whether we are saving lives and
keeping people out of the hospital
that's been true since the beginning it
is true now as well and by that measure
our vaccines are still doing a good job
and you need the booster in particular
though because with omicron there's some
invasion of the immune response not all
the immune response but some of it but
the booster helps restore the protection
that you get from your two doses so that
is the most important measure are we
keeping people out of the hospital are
we saving lives with that said you know
wherever possible we want to reduce the
number of infections because we want to
prevent people from getting long covered
we know there are still many people who
are unvaccinated including kids under
five we want to protect them also from
exposure to the virus
but now we're hearing dr murthy about uh
breakthrough
breakthrough cases with boosters we used
to be told that if you get your booster
it provides you maximum protection i
hear you say if you get it you're gonna
be okay but that's still not comforting
you get the booster because you think
i'm going to be protected now how are we
supposed to process this information and
not be afraid
as we look at the long lines of people
well it's
yeah it's a really important question
gail and i just want to say i recognize
that with omicron and all of this news
this can be a scary time for people and
it can be fatiguing as well right we've
been at this for two years but here's
how to think about the the booster shot
the booster reduces your chances of
certainly getting severely ill and it
reduces your chances of getting sick in
the first place but no vaccine is
perfect and especially against a foe
like omicron we know that there are
going to be some people who despite
getting boosted they may get what are
called breakthrough infections but those
infections are much more likely to be
mild uh compared to maybe somebody who
is not boosted or not vaccinated who may
have a you know a greater chance of
ending up in the hospital so the bottom
line is you have to isolate if you get a
break very well
if you get a breakthrough do you have to
isolate
yes so if you get an infection uh
whether you've infected been vaccinated
or not you should isolate because you're
at risk of spreading it to others
all right doctor as it relates to covert
it's oftentimes described as a fight so
sticking with the theme if i'm watching
a boxing match i can tell who's winning
so i have to ask you who's winning this
fight is it covet or or is it us
well we are certainly in a much better
place than we were a year ago and the
reason is this we have more tools in our
toolbox we have the vaccines and the
boosters we know our masks work to
reduce spread our testing can also be a
strategy to make gatherings safer
especially important before you get
together for the holidays and we know
how important ventilation is now not
something we fully appreciated a year
ago and so when you gather gathering in
well-vented ventilated places can also
make your gathering safer so we are in a
better place with better tools and
better knowledge and that's why i
actually feel confident despite omicron
coming on the scene that we have the
tools to get through this pandemic we've
got to stick together though in this
process we can't let this pandemic
splinter us
dr moorthy we're running out of time but
since you mentioned tools and you
mentioned testing there's a conversation
we've been hearing about in the medical
world about whether all the tests out
there including the antigen test at home
can actually detect omicron are you
aware of that conversation and can you
say this morning that all tests can
indeed detect omicron
we're absolutely aware of these
conversations and in fact making sure
that our tests are working working well
has been an important priority of the
fda since omicron came on the scene the
good news is that the data that they've
seen so far in their testing has been
reassuring that the vast majority of
tests that americans are using are
working and working well they're going
to continue to monitor this and make
sure that they
yeah are there are there certain tests
that americans should be aware of as
they go into the holiday gathering
period that you should stay away from
because they don't work
well the fda has listed publicly on its
website a few tests which it has some
concerns about but those don't include
the vast majority of tests that people
are buying over the counter in their
pharmacies so the bottom line is if
you're getting an over-the-counter test
you know this is an important tool that
you can use to help you make your
gathering safer and at this point we can
feel confident that those tests are
still serving us and serving as well
dr vivek morty thank you so much for
joining us and answering the questions
that we all need to know we appreciate
you